alors le coup de coeur du si 17 cette
semaine c'est évidemment la troisième
édition du festival saint quentin avec
quatre événements aussi 17 vendredi soir
ce qu'il faut de silence un documentaire
sur la genèse on va dire d'un opéra
entrée libre samedi à 18h30 on aura le
plaisir de recevoir youssef qui a fait
l'objet d'un film réalisé par un
réalisateur et un serment qui sera aussi
présent youssef le gant bridon qui
viendra aussi jouer de son instrument
artisanal fabriqué chez lui avec les
moyens du bord
dimanche matin à 10h30 la petite musique
des bruits si les filous pour les
tout-petits autour de la musique donc le
thème du festival et l'après midi entrée
libre aussi réservations au 01 30 51 03
02 la clôture du festival à partir de 16
heures en partenariat avec l'école de
musique qu'il jouera des morceaux de
musique de films dans la salle
ensuite la projection du documentaire
sur pierre barou et la remise des prix
du festival tous a suivi par un petit
cocktail voilà j'espère à cette semaine
dans nos salles